Hi, my name is Daniel
[? Orchansky ?].
I'm an intern here on the
Android team at Google.
And today I'll be talking about
some folding animation.
It's a folding animation kind
of like an accordion, except
you can specify the number of
folds, the orientation, as
well as the anchor point along
which the fold is going to
take place.
So now while you'll be able to
fold any image, as you'll see
that very soon.
And the trick behind doing this
is noting that given some
number of folds, you can split
an image into several
different segments.
Each of these segments is a
rectangle that can then be
transformed in various ways
using major transformations.
And then, in order to make the
fold even more realistic, what
I'm going to do is use gradients
along with a
shadow-like effect on
alternating folds to actually
get that real folding-like
effect.
In this demo, it's important
to know that there's fold
factor that I'm going to
be using that varies
between zero and one.
And what's going to happen
when something has a fold
factor of zero.
It means that it's completely
unfolded.
Whereas when something has a
fold factor of one, it means
that it's completely folded to
the point where you cannot see
it anymore.
So that being, said,
let's jump in
straight into the demo.
So here we have just an image.
And I'm going to start
folding it.
And as I'm moving my
finger, you can see
the image gets folded.
And then it gets unfolded.
This is four folds.
You change the anchor point
of where it's happening.
And once again, the same
thing applies here.
I can change the number of folds
to eight if I want to.
And the other thing you're
noticing is this kind of sepia
effect as I'm animating.
And I can turn that off.
It's a cool little feature I
thought would add a lot to
this, which I'll show you how
to implement in a second.
And the other thing about this
is that you can even fold not
just that static image, but also
a live camera feed if you
use something like
a texture here.
So here we have our camera
crew and unfolding and
unfolding it.
So it is a live image that is
being folded an unfolded.
OK, so that being said, let's
jump straight into the code.
And the way this works is
folding layout extends the
view group.
So this is very generalized,
except it is set up in such a
way such that my layout
can only ever have,
at most, one child.
But then again, this one child
can be a layout that you can
populate any way that you
want, and then fold--
even a user interface, with a
buttons and text boxes if
you'd like.
So scrolling down, here I'm
doing a lot of checks.
So if you're trying to add more
than one view, what's
going to happen is that I'm
actually going to throw an
exception because, in this
context, that's not something
that's being supported.
And once we get through that,
then there's all the setters.
So like I mentioned before,
you can set
the number of folds.
You can set the orientation.
And you can also set the
number of folds, the
orientation, and the
anchor point along
which it's being folded.
So I'm not showing the
orientation change yet, but
the same thing applies when you
are in the vertical, as
opposed to horizontal,
orientation.
So then here you can set the
fold factor, which is, again,
a value between zero and one.
And every single time you set
the fold factor, you need to
calculate matrices
and invalidate.
So invalidate will draw the
new folded view onto your
canvas in it's new
folded state.
And calculate matrices actually
calculates all the
transformation matrices that
you need to go from the
unfolded image to the folded
one to some degree.
For every single time some other
parameter gets changed,
we need to call this method
called update fold, which does
all the preparation for actually
folding a new image.
So in update fold, we're going
to call prepare fold.
And all prepare fold really
does is return all our
variables to default because
this is now a new image.
It allocates space for all the
transformation matrices we
need, the paint objects,
the gradient objects,
and things like that.
It sets up the gradient objects
that we're going to
need for later, stores all the
values we're going to need,
stores the original widths and
heights of the images.
And the most important thing
that it does is right here,
where it splits the image
into rectangles.
So like I said before, in order
to fold something, what
you need to do is split it into
separate segments, so you
how each segment should
be transformed.
But every single segment is
just a simple rectangle.
So I'm going to store all these
rectangles in an array.
And I'm going to be referencing
these rectangles
as the source for every
single transformation
that I'll be doing.
So that's on the fold.
Then in calculating the
matrices, this is where we
actually calculate the
transformation matrix.
I'm not going to go through
the math of how I did
everything.
But the main thing to note here
is that you need to make
sure that you reset your
transformation matrix on every
single time the fold factor
gets changed.
And the other thing to note is
that the amount that a fold
should be folded by is inversely
proportional to the
distance from which it
is away from you.
So for example, when you start
folding it, you'll that edges
very quickly start going into
the page, whereas when it's
already really folded,
the edges don't go
into the page as much.
A simple inverse relation
achieves this.
And that's how you
get the fold.
So back in calculating matrices,
there's a listener
that I added on end fold
and on start fold.
So what this gives you is is
just kind of a listener you
can listen to when a fold
ends or starts.
And scrolling down past all
the math, what we're doing
here is we're going to be
transforming a set of eight
points to another set
of eight points.
Since every single segment is
a rectangle, every single
vertex has two points.
An x and a y coordinate.
So given the eight points from
the source, and the eight
points in the desination, we'll
be able to achieve the
transformation that we need.
So how we do that is using the
function available in matrix,
in Andrew's matrix API
called, poly to
poly, set poly to poly.
And what this does is this
take an array of source
points, an array of destination
points, and the
number of points you're
going to use.
So in this case, that
will be four.
And this is limited
to four at most.
And so all that's going to do
is give us a matrix that
transforms that original
rectangle to this new rectangle.
And in order to then imagine the
graphical effect here, the
destination source has its edges
kind of curved in, as
opposed to just a rectangle,
where all the sides are
parallel and perpendicular
to each other.
And scrolling down farther more,
the other thing we need
to do is scale our gradient.
So if you saw in the fold, every
other fold has a very
solid kind of overlay black
shadow over it.
But that every fold in between
that just has a small gradient
going across it to achieve that
more realistic effect.
So the alpha value, as well as
the size and scale for all of
these are all calculated here.
Then, in this batch draw,
there's a couple optimizations
that we have.
For example, if the fold factor
is equal to zero, and
it's completely unfolded, no
folding needs to happen, so we
just draw the original
image and call super.
In some other cases, like if
it's equal to 1, then we don't
want to draw anything.
And then what we're going to do
is loop through all of our
folds and just start drawing
each and every fold into our
canvas separately.
So right here, first, what we do
is concatenate our canvas.
First we need to save the state
of our current canvas.
Then we concatenate our
canvas with the
transformation matrix.
We need to clip [? our rect ?]
because all we really want to
show, for every single time,
is one segment at a time.
So we clip that rectangle.
We transform it appropriately
so that it's located in the
beginning of the view because
our transformation matrix, if
you look the map later, takes
things from the very far left
and then puts it in the correct
position on the screen.
Recall super and
dispatch draw.
And since the canvas is clipped,
what this is going to
do is only draw that clipped
section of the canvas that we
have specified.
Then we transit our
canvas back.
And then using the same matrix
information, we'll also draw
the solid shadows as well as the
gradient shadow on top the
folds that we've already
drawn above.
So one of the biggest problems
that we actually encounter
while working on this is that in
Android 4.3, a new bug was
introduced where if you call
super.dispatchdraw multiple
times within one call to
dispatchdraw, it won't
actually have the same effect
as it does on 4.2
and prior to that.
What's going to happen is all
the canvas transformations are
going to be delayed until the
last canvas transformation.
And only that last one that
will actually take effect.
This is now a bug, which
a patch will be
uploaded in the future.
But in the meantime, there's
a small work around that we
found, which only works for
static images, not the like
camera feed that you
saw earlier.
And the way this works is, in
prepare fold, what we're going
to do first is capture the
actual bitmap that we can see.
So we're just going to take
the child and capture that
whole thing in a bitmap.
The matrix transformations
are going to remain
completely the same.
But the only difference we're
going to be is here.
So if it is GBMR2, so Android
4.3, instead of calling super
to dispatch draw and then
transmitting canvas itself,
all we're going to do is take
our bitmap, specify a source
and a destination rectangle
within our bitmap, and then
use that transformation matrix
to draw only that segment from
that bitmap onto the screen
where we want to.
So it will have the exact same
effect on static images, but
it will not have the
same effect--
it's actually, it will not
work for something like a
texture that continuously
updates.
The last thing that I just want
to show is how we add the
sepia effect.
So there's a lot of boilerplate
code in this file
to handle all the touch events,
but here in on fold
listener, which is the custom
listener that we created, all
we're going to be doing is
adding a hardware layer on top
of our view.
And when you set a hardware
layer, what you can also do is
specify a paint object.
So if it is a hardware
layer, you can
specify a paint object.
And that paint object gets
applied onto the view that has
that layer.
And if you look at sepia
paint it's a very
simple color filter.
They use a couple of color
matrices with some values.
And by overlaying that onto the
view, you get the sepia
effect as you're folding it,
which can be very easily
turned on and off by removing
the layer off of our view.
So that's ow you do cool
folding animation.
Thanks for watching.